broadly speaking we're what's going to
work well I think of what is working
perhaps more appropriately today I think
there are two ways that the average
investor should think of investing one
is are you going to create a good
strategic asset allocation mix that is a
balanced portfolio that means that
you're not going to go to the betting
table and bet against active investors
like me look odd I'm scared of being
wrong in the market it is not easy to
win in the market it is more difficult
to win in the markets than to compete in
the Olympics hang on a second hang on a
second you guys have an extraordinary
track record of winning yeah is it
harder to compete in the markets today
than it has been since you found a
bridgewater no I don't think so really
not the way we do it and the reason I'm
saying not the way we do it is we don't
take systematic biases I think for a lot
of people they're systematically long
everything you know and so we have a
world in which there when the world gets
bad it's bad for them in 2008 it was
great for us I don't know we had nearly
10 percent return in 2008 so we have the
opportunity to go either way we just may
be wrong okay if we're wrong so so I'm
so scared about being wrong that it has
helped reduce my chances of being wrong
because I'm so scared I won't take bets
that on you know that I don't feel good
about and we diversify our portfolio and
that's how we we we got the track record
I was just commenting in terms of se
let's say so you asked me about
investors so I'm trying to go back what
an investor should do well absolutely
and what you think is appropriate so
here's what I'm trying you guys are
doing well I want to just convey to
investors I think in the average
investor most everybody don't compete
against pros like ourselves or other
people don't making tactical asset
allocation bets or moving around in the
markets because you're probably going to
lose it's difficult for us really
beautifully Chris's points no you have
to have a devout a balanced portfolio in
other words think about how you're going
to have a balanced portfolio what you
know is that asset class as a whole over
a period of time we're going to
outperform cash mm-hmm okay that's the
most thing that you could be most
comfortable with if they don't you have
a depression the only times that hasn't
happened but to know how to achieve a
back
balance portfolio and that's a whole
other subject I don't know that you want
to go through if you're talking about
tactical bets in other words I can come
on the show and I could say I think this
is good but then what happens is if I
come a month later and I then change my
mind because something has happened then
I'm going to leave something I'm going
to mislead people so that the tactical
bets I don't think are going to be
helpful I would say that we're in an
environment in which it's very important
to have a well diversified and that'll
include assets like to some extent maybe
a little bit of gold in your portfolio
in other words what could I tell
investors try to achieve balance in
various ways that's a whole subject
about how to do it and also I think that
the you know a gold you know at five
percent of your portfolio five or ten
percent of your portfolio under the
circumstances would be also a prudent
thing to do prudence is the important
thing to do the reason I'm also
referring to that is we have a situation
where a debt is money in other words we
have a Fiat monetary system too and so
we're having problems as these central
banks operate and so that it's a think
of it as another form of cash and when
cash now has zero or or zero percent
interest rates or less think of it as
one of those possibilities in terms of
how do you how do you create
diversification